aujourd'hui nos aînés sont maltraités
dans les ehpad en france ouais
c'est à dire on leur fait quoi mais on
les aide pas on n'est pas là pour eux on
les abandonne on a l'impression non en
tant que soignant alors que c'est notre
vocation et c'est un métier qu'on a
choisi par vocation et des maltraitances
oui à des maltraitances quel jour pas
des maltraitances physiques parce qu'on
n'est pas là pour frapper nos résidents
on n'est pas là pour ça mais à des
maltraitance institutionnelle quand vous
avez une direction qui vous impose
d'utiliser simplement trois couches par
jour et que vous avez des résidents mais
fais moi je vais pas trois fois aux
toilettes dans la journée ça m'arrive
d'aller plus souvent mais si j'ai une
couche et que j'ai aux toilettes et
qu'on me dit on remet la ta couche parce
que
parce qu'on en a pas d'autres je ne me
vois pas remettre une couche salle mais
je pense que personne ici ce revers et
mettre une couche salle quand vous avez
des résidentes qui ont les repas avait
son service super toi on me l'a pu le
voir là c'est 18 heures quand depuis
déjà 18 heures vous avez plus rien dans
le ventre jusqu'au lendemain matin était
déjà 18 heures on vous a pas servi à
grand chose le lendemain matin on vous
dit ab ce matin vous aurez qu'une
boisson parce qu'on a plus de madeleine
et quand on se sera un verre d'eau parce
qu'on a plus de jus de fruits
quand vous payez plus de 5000 euros que
vous avez travaillé toute votre vie que
vous arrivez à la fin de votre vie et
que vous avez envie juste de partir
paisiblement et d'apprécier les derniers
jours qui vous reste quand on vous fait
subir mais ça c'est de la maltraitance